and i just don't know how
you keep it together
i don't
certainly with jb smoove standing there
with his bag of chips
and then just chiming in in the middle
of all that larry david i mean like that
guy
he's just the greatest hold on one
second so we're back here on our radio
network just joining us we're talking
with larry david just showed us a clip
jb's how do you keep it together yeah i
said i don't it's it's impossible
a half half of the takes i'm i'm
laughing
particularly with jb i mean they're all
they're all so funny that cass jb
uh susie and jeff cheryl ted all of them
and
uh vince vaughn was on a number of shows
again this year he is fantastic
fantastic he plays funkhouser's
nephew or something like that
step brother
oh my gosh so um
we're back on curb and richard's in one
show this year richard lewis is in one
show this year you know he was on here a
few years ago to promote curb yeah and
he said that the two of you went to
dinner together
and that you ordered a whole bunch of
food at some uh chinese restaurant there
yeah mr challenge okay and that he said
that you left
him in the middle of the meal because
you forgot there was a poker night yeah
yeah
that's true yeah that's true so it's
true yeah all of a sudden i realized oh
my god i forgot my poker game you know
yeah i i said i'm so sorry uh uh i'll
you know i'll i'll make it up to you and
and he literally left him i left him
there yeah he said it was like you
ordered what do you say it was like a
peacock or something like that
that's what he said that it was like
some sort of crazy ordering that you had
a whole bunch come to the table your
phone rang he said it was steve martin
yes it was steve martin's so he was
telling the truth yeah he was telling
the truth yeah so you're in a poker game
with steve martin no i played uh
i played in that game uh i i think once
or twice okay yeah and you forgot so you
just leave richard with the with the
bill and everything he said you left him
yeah i left him with everything yeah
yeah and i left them alone yeah
how do you follow up on that you know i
had an obligation to the game there's
got to be you got to have at least six
players right yes for a game to be
interesting you don't want to play with
five can't you can't do the split hands
i like the split hands right
so um
yeah i felt i had an obligation to the
game not to him yeah
[Laughter]
because when he told that story all of
us here we were all like saying that
sounds like an episode of curb one two
we thought like he had to have been
embellishing some just no he did not i i
heard him on the show i heard the story
okay he did not embellish anything
that was that was
to the letter
which which uh which cast member cracks
you up the most uh first of all i
wouldn't say okay um
but
you know i
sometimes it'll be on friday a friday
night and everybody wants to go home
sure the crew
it's 10 o'clock at night they they want
to go home
and i'm
laughing during takes
and i i apolo i go i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry but look did you hear what he said
you know
and and because we're improvising i'm
hearing i'm hearing it for the first
time
so
it's hard not to
laugh so you're laughing all the time
i know i put you in a position yeah you
don't want to say one cast members no
how dare you how dare you i know
who do you like best here in the studio
you know
actually i i like tj thanks right there
yeah i'll be honest with you
he just showed his empty chair right
there
because tj's
manning the phone right there shooting
this whole um this whole conversation
larry david here on the rich eisen show
so uh i'll i'll i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
you the question uh that i always want
to know the answer to everybody wants to
know the answer to
is this it is this oh larry god rich
don't don't don't do this to me now no
why not because it's it's too soon it's
way too soon okay yeah so you need to
see how everything goes well i need to
see how i feel i mean you know it's a
it's a huge mountain to climb to
first of all to ride it
and shoot it get it yeah it's eight it's
about uh 18 months from beginning to end
um so
it's it's a big obligation
i will just say this yeah please don't
stop okay okay
on behalf of
every human being on the planet that's a
slight exaggeration it's not in a slight
exaggeration i i honestly it is because
it's just so spot on
over and over and over again
with
skewering what we live in every single
day and what we want to say about these
situations
and it's we just showed a clip here and
it's
as good as ever so i just wanted to say
that in front of everybody here to say
that
thank you that's very nice of you um i'm
not i'm not being coy when i can't give
an answer because i really don't know
the answer right okay well at any rate
it premieres on uh this sunday night at
october 24th again on hbo on sunday
night
once again larry i have here for you
sure a list
of
social situations that we are frequently
in okay as human beings on planet earth
in this day and age am i answering as me
or as tv larry no i i i need you
david you are the judge and jury for
these social situations okay i have a
handful we have we have uh we've quizzed
the the crew here and the staff and
we've all come together and we think
these are good for for you to to tell us
what's right and what's wrong okay here
we go first one up uh you're at a
restaurant okay and uh you're with
others
and do you
have to wait until everyone else gets
their food to start eating larry david
that
that rule
okay that waiting until everybody gets
served yes that is just
beyond dumb i mean
it is so
stupid it's torture i can't stand it
when people you see they're starving
they're looking at the food it's right
in front of them you're waiting for me
don't be ridiculous no you must eat so
much and by the way we did this on curb
when was this we did this we did this on
curb second season long time ago
somebody bid on some kind of charity to
have lunch with me right for some uh
reason i don't know why right
groats it was grouch disease okay
named after dick road of course yeah
i remember this yeah it was ghost
disease and and my my tuna sandwich came
and uh i said i said to the guy who's
paying money to have lunch with me i
said do you mind if i get started and he
said yeah i do and of course you know
that's a problem yeah but but you think
that hot food cold food doesn't matter
it doesn't matter start eating no but
you understand that other people have a
differing point of view so do you start
eating or do you ask for permission to
start eating you just get in for
yourself you mean when you mean if i'm
in this situation me larry david food
first yeah right do you just go
i'll look at him and i'll go
[Laughter]
off you can they all go oh yeah yeah
yeah but you as somebody who's waiting
for your food immediately let everyone
off the hook i just as soon as it comes
start eating yeah okay you'll make me
uncomfortable all right that's number
one number two
uh spoilers what is the time period
that it's okay to say for a tv show or a
movie what a spoiler is do you have any
thoughts on that subject
about tv spoilers in other words giving
away the story to something yes yes i i
have an opinion on that what is your
rule on that what do you think
first of all ask if they've seen it
okay right never ever blurt it out even
if it's a year a year yeah
you don't blurt out any any information
regarding an ending
uh of anything
okay for a show
but you ask you say did you happen to
see this
can i tell you about it
then you'll get your answer about
anything yeah that's been in on in the
last calendar year
somebody sent me a text yes uh jeff
schafer
jeff schaeffer sent me your collaborator
except my collaborator my
our director sent me a text yes okay
knows what a jet fan i am
sent me a text
during the game
because i tape the games if i'm if i'm
golfing i'll take the you know i tape
the games yes
and he sends me a text giving away
giving away what happened in the game
and i said to him
you have to assume tape
why don't you assume tape
well this is another subject entirely
live sports yeah you have to assume that
you always always assume tape you never
give away a score ever
never
wow especially if you know especially
you know the person roots for that teen
yes correct or at least say are you
watching the game or are you taping oh
so in the same way that it's just like
come on use your head you got to use
your head
you can't be an idiot
my cousin my cousin sent me a uh
some some not my cousin no a friend of
mine from new york yeah i taped the
ranger games
um
sent me the score of the ranger game
sent me a complaint about the ranges i
go you got he assumed tape i'm taping
i taped the game you do know and i'm i
am mandated to say this that
in the sports live sports world it is
assumed it's on you to perform some form
of
seal around your life where you're it's
on you to black yourself out no
no you do not feel i don't think that's
fair suppose i have some kind of
emergency for my kids i'm not allowed to
check my phone all day
no you have to assume tape
that's larry david on sports that's my
motto that's my motto assume tape here's
another good one larry david
if someone offers you a ticket to go to
a game a sporting event okay i'm liking
this is it wrong to ask where the seats
are before accepting absolutely not
it's the same thing if somebody invites
you to a dinner party yes
who's going
why not why not be able to say who's
going right
okay sure
okay i don't want to sit next to
somebody i can't stand for three hours
but if i'm offering you a ticket to the
game it's basically like let's hang out
i've you know paid for the ticket i'm
assuming that they're gonna that's all
very well and good but no
okay so
don't don't put me up in the bleachers
that's what
where is the point of demarcation within
a stadium or an arena where you would
then reject
the offer
for the ticket to go to a game larry
well
i i'd have to see where the seats are
okay you would have to map it you'd map
it i'd map it yeah i would definitely
map it
and then i would have no qualms and
saying to the person ah
and i don't like where they talk yeah
by the way your reaction to being on the
on the on the sofi stadium scoreboard
yeah where they showed you you were like
you know yeah whatever that was
fantastic oh thanks you're welcome let
you know let a man breathe
so okay so you'd have to map it as or as
uh
jb would say
can an mf
this is what he said in one of the
scenes yeah can an mf live
you know we've sent jb into how many was
it five or six
five super bowl media
nights for our show
and just asking questions mostly of the
patriots because three out of the five
super bowls he asked the belichick and
brady and yeah he was phenomenal as you
might imagine greatest he's the greatest
all right here's a another one for you
right here i got two more left uh when
ordering food or coffee at a
drive-through are you required to know
your order already ahead of time when
you get to the speaker
to order larry if there are cars behind
you
it behooves you mm-hmm
okay
to be prepared
it's it's rude and inconsiderate to keep
people waiting
so it's just you know it's easy it's
golden rule that's golden rule
but you're so you have to know the menu
ahead of time oh you're oh knowing the
oh cause you don't have the menu
yeah no in that case i get out of the
car
i look at the car behind i go i i don't
know the menu i'm so sorry
i don't i don't know the menu you give
the international center i give this i'm
so sorry look you know
just give i'm so sorry
how much time do you have then to order
do you think well you want to hurry up
at that point of course right now and
then if you can't decide you turn back
no i i i i don't know i can't decide
yeah
here's a bonus one off of that is it
when somebody's driving improperly or
slowly oh do you give the look do you
not give a little does it make you feel
better
to just see the face and the person
who's performing so poorly because i
always want to know what the poor driver
looks like
always
why i i don't know i want to see i want
to see this incompetent face you know
it's very important to me so i will pass
and give a look no pass and look yeah i
will pass in luck yeah
because i i do that too and i don't know
why it gives me such satisfaction to
know what they look like i don't know i
i agree it's a mystery but but you want
to know you just
you don't want to be in the dark about
that okay here's the last one for you
which we're very
curious i guess you want to see what
stupidity looks like
what is the face of stupidity that's
what we're talking about so you can
avoid it the next time or you just no
just
yeah i guess you get it inside your
brain yes oh that's a stupid face i'll
be on the lookout for faces similar to
that yeah it's like face recognition at
airports exactly yeah it's stupid yeah
stupid recognition
all right last one for you larry david i
have a very
personally a very definite opinion about
this um by the way may i say yes
excellent question thank you sir all of
them all of them excellent questions
thank you i appreciate that where it
gives us pride that you know i i
appreciate a good a good question okay
uh last one
is it okay
to play music in a speaker inside a golf
cart
when you're on a golf course
larry david
okay this is this is a very good
question thank you sir
and i am saying
if i own the golf course do i own the
golf course
you do not own the golf course why can't
i own the golf course you may own the
golf i own the golf course that's one of
the rules you could you can you can play
music and yes and you in your golf cart
yeah but you don't own the golf course
like you're just playing golf with
somebody i mean yeah okay they have like
okay here's what i would say yeah
a lot of times in golf
there are other foursomes or other
people playing yeah who can't who don't
know what's going on and and you know in
your foursome yeah so you could you
could play like i i play with guys and
we in the summer um and we play music
you do yeah we do i just i i'm i'm
anti-music i go to the golf course just
to hear nothing i get so much maybe it's
my job i hear they get stuff on my ears
all the time i hear everything for some
reason i'm uh i attract ambient noise
everywhere i go in every part of my life
not to unburden myself but i just i i
just want to hear the birds and the
nothing mean
i thought so too i don't hear jimmy
buffett i thought so too but you know if
if you get if you get the right uh
mix
really
yeah if it's like a some kind of
seventies thing you know it was got rock
are you a yacht rock guys
[Laughter]
i didn't think i would like it either
but yes it kind of uh puts you in a
little bit of a better mood and you need
to be in a better mood when you play
golf because it's
yes
101
last week you yes
music the 101 101.
it was
i was so depressed
i was so sick i was sick i was ill
i was ill i wanted to cry i could cry if
i had let myself go i could have cried
i didn't even hang out afterwards to
have a
soda you got nothing i i had to go i had
to go home and i had to bury my head in
my wife's bosom
i was so upset
[Laughter]
that swan episode of curb yeah was one
of the greatest episodes yeah that was a
good one of all time how do you go back
to your your golf course after something
like that did you was it uh a dicey
scenario for yourself let's best we move
on
let's go back to the 101 yeah
well that's all we got those are our
questions right here great question
that's it right there questions you know
what because we always just want to get
your thoughts yeah no
boring issues really good really good
these very
there's another one where we got you
there's your judging jerry there you are
in your robe
um larry david you are the best thank
you for doing this i greatly appreciate
it
and congrats on the season that's to
come and the uh the
the kudos that are going to be coming
your way this season is remarkable curb
your enthusiasm again premieres this
sunday on hbo season 11 may there be
more years larry david good to see you
to see you hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here